obviously as you mentioned yesterday a
tough story I think as far as not just
reckoning people want results and part
of that is this report which of course
they're advocating for transparency but
we're not even sure exactly when that
report well you know I am so sorry again
that it's so close to home for us you
know I'm sick and sick of the story and
sickened by everything that we keep
hearing but the part you mentioned about
transparency is very disturbing to me
because I would think how can we have
this investigation and not know how it
comes out les Moonves has been on the
record he says listen he didn't do these
things that it was consensual that he
hasn't hurt anybody's career and I would
think it would be in his best interest
for us to hear what the report finds out
on the other hand you have women who are
coming forward very credibly talking
about something that's so painful and so
humiliating it's been my experience that
women don't come out and speak this way
for no reason they just don't they just
don't do it
and so I don't know how we move forward
if we don't we at CBS don't have full
transparency about what we find John you
know I wasn't here yesterday because I
was in a wedding in Europe as you guys
know but I thought it was interesting
when you said a friend of yours said for
30 years this has haunted her because we
of course we're talking about it all
weekend and someone said what how does
anybody remember what happened 30 years
ago when it is that traumatic and that
humiliating you remember every single
detail like it had happened it's not
just it's not just in the moment it's
when you go to the lawyer and the lawyer
says it's your word against against his
so that sense of powerlessness lives
with you forever in our own house we
must have transparency and I certainly
feel for Julie Chen today you know she's
in a very difficult position and you
know les Moonves has done some wonderful
things for this company and we can't
forget that either so it's just a bad
situation all the way around but I'm
glad that we are covering the story it's
important that we cover it and get to
the bottom of wherever it whatever it is
right you're right down but you know
thank you tarika